ancient human civilization was far older
and far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school in fact we were a
global civilization that spanned
multiple continents around the world and
in this video I'm going to show you key
evidence ranging from South America the
Mid East Southeast Asia and when you
connect it all it far exceeds the realm
of just a coincidence now real quick
then they get the big question out of
the way that most people have when they
hear this information for the first time
which is okay if we were so advanced
what happened to us or where's the
evidence like metal buildings well you
must first take into consideration that
there was a massive global Cataclysm
that happened 13,000 years ago and a
second event fourteen hundred years
later it's very likely that a asteroid
hit the North American ice shelf which
caused a massive 400 foot rise in sea
level around the world in a 15 degree
Fahrenheit temperature swing and a
massive extinction level event of many
mammals I actually have two videos on
this which I highly recommend you check
them out because the evidence is
genuinely conclusive that these events
happened and as far as metal buildings
we must take into consideration just how
long of a period of time thirteen
thousand years ago is I mean we hear
figures like okay the dinosaurs
apparently went extinct 66 million years
ago so when we hear figures like 13,000
years ago most of us think okay well
that's not that long ago but take for
example the Titanic which in just a
couple days will have been at the bottom
of the Atlantic Ocean for 105 years
nearly 50,000 tons of steel and iron is
just disintegrated and in just a few
hundred more years it will be as if it
never existed in the first place take
even cars as an example if you leave
them outside for just a few decades they
rust straight through and completely
just get immersed into the earth and
within a few hundred years they're
non-existent as well or even houses if
you don't restore house within a few
decades that roof will cave in the walls
will cave in and the same thing happens
to it as well so just imagine what could
happen over a period of a thousand years
or five thousand years or even ten or
thirteen thousand years ago quite
literally the only thing that survives
that long period of time is stone now
let's dive right into the evidence there
are two lines that connect several
ancient civilizations and megalithic
structures ranging from Easter Island
to Machu Picchu in Peru which is right
by the Nazca lines as well as Cusco and
Sasuke women which is so mysterious and
how these walls were built and how these
megalithic stones were constructed and
when you connect the line from Easter
Island which is so mysterious to Peru
all the way across the Atlantic to Mali
Africa which is the location of the
Dogon people if I pronounced that
correctly which for some reason in
ancient times they were aware of star
Sirius B which is invisible to the naked
eye and it's not something that was
apparently discovered for thousands of
years later yet somehow they have
legends and tales of it and this also
coincides with the Sumerians allegedly
the birthplace of civilization in
Mesopotamia that they somehow were aware
of the planets within our own solar
system they knew that the earth was
bigger than Mars and that Jupiter was
bigger than Saturn and Saturn bigger
than Uranus and and so on and yet these
planets were not supposed to have been
discovered for thousands of years later
but they somehow knew about it and
etched it in stone and on clay tablets
that were discovered thousands of years
later it's a total mystery
now when you connect the line straight
through the Pyramids of Giza and the
Sphinx all the way through to Jordan
where Petra is located the underground
city of Petra which is so mysterious and
of itself it can hold more than 20,000
people no one knows who built it or when
and even just a year ago they found an
entirely new entrance with incredible
architecture more than 160 feet high and
when you connect a line through Petra it
goes over to the persopolis in Iran
which is mysterious and of itself and
there's many theories and who built it
in one however when you consider other
ancient civilizations and megalithic
structures we find an entirely other new
line that goes from Mesopotamia in where
is apparently the birthplace of Muhammad
and was just a key site in the Sumerian
culture and if you connect that line
over to Pakistan to the ancient
civilization of mohenjo-daro and when
you continue that line over to Southeast
Asia running through ancient sites in
Burma all the way over to Cambodia which
is the famous site of Angoor walk which
is very mysterious it's a site of much
speculation and debate but ultimately
there are two lines that intersect in
these lines I mean really is it just a
coincidence that all of these megalithic
sites just
happen to be completely connected along
two lines is it possible that it's not a
coincidence well when you tie in other
key pieces of evidence ranging from
South America to Egypt to Southeast Asia
you see that oh my goodness there are
incredible similarities between
architecture stone structures whether
it's the similarities of pyramids or
even the use of obelisks or the use of
trapezoidal doors which I've never seen
before but they just so happen to be
located and found in ancient Egypt as
well as the Incan culture in Peru or
even take the example of gold funeral
masks that were utilized by the Indians
and the Egyptians as well and it doesn't
stop there just when you consider how
they were able to cut in carve these
massive stones and place them and yet
they share similarities across multiple
continents around the world you have to
start asking questions they even have
similarities between the depiction of
the third eye as well as animals it's
located at the center of foreheads and
like I said when you consider the
similarities between architecture and
stone structures and buildings across
multiple continents and when you look at
these similarities you have to ask
yourself were they built by the same
people now this leads me to one major
point which is DNA evidence how is it
that they're able to find middle-eastern
DNA found in Native Americans of North
America or even Aboriginal DNA from
Australia found in mummies in South
America this is completely unexplainable
in a total mystery to scientist and
these articles you can find are a year
old and they are actively still
researching this topic all together but
they all agree that it's mysterious and
to be honest it completely debunked the
known narrative of the human migrate
migration process across the world and
the evidence goes much further than that
in fact they're finding Egyptian mummies
with traces of cocaine which is a
complete mystery considering that
cocaine the cocoa plant originates in
South America yet Egyptians had this
thousands of years ago somehow when
those plants originated nowhere near
that region of the world so how is that
possible I mean after all when you
consider these incredible lines that
connect megalithic structures and
ancient civilizations that are so
mysterious and of themselves we consider
the incredible similarities between
cultures stone structures
stone buildings and DNA evidence and we
combined all of this information
together it's abundantly clear that
there was a global civilization that
existed and we were wiped out back to
the Stone Age approximately 13,000 years
ago and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago when these two massive
cataclysms happened here on earth which
we know of and yet the mainstream
scientists and archeologists and story
ins no one wants to touch on the subject
of the Cataclysm and again watch the two
videos that I put out and there's other
topics and people to discuss this as
well I highly recommend you check out
the works of Graham Hancock who outlines
this in detail on Graham Hancock calm
and he was covering this from as far
back as 2001 it's incredible and he goes
into much further detail of how these
megalithic sites connect around the
world in incredible patterns that to be
honest are far more impressive than what
I discussed here today and be sure to
check out his podcast with Joe Rogan and
Randall Carlson where they discuss all
the overwhelming evidence of the
Cataclysm also check out the works of
Brian Forrester who has a YouTube
channel as well as a website hidden in
Catorce comm and by the way real quick I
don't know any of these people but their
works have been are so incredible and
the mainstream scientists are trying to
keep these guys out of the picture it's
insane even though they have evidence
that's overwhelming so check out these
individuals yourself come to your own
conclusions when we start connecting the
dots and how they're able to cut and
carve stones that even modern-day stone
masons completely disagree with and when
you look at how well okay the primitive
methods that have been suggested
suggested by archaeologists and
Egyptologists don't compute because of
the tens of millions of stone blocks
statues and structures found just in
Egypt alone could not have been done
with those primitive methods anywhere
within the realm of time in fact they'd
still be working on them today so
something doesn't add up
we were absolutely far older and we're
far more advanced than the textbooks are
currently teaching everyone in school
anyways I'll leave it at that like and
subscribe leave me a comment and share
your thoughts and I have many other
videos and a whole wide variety of
topics take care everybody